le plus haut tribunal des états unis a
réduit une partie des pouvoirs de
l'agencé de protection environnementale
le pea qui est dit que la réglementation
sur les émissions de gaz carbonique la
cour suprême est d'avis que c'est au
congrès de trancher et d'établir ces
normes
l' affaire remonte à 2015 le président
barack obama avait fait adopter des lois
qui réduisent le plafond d'émissions de
gaz carbonique que peuvent produire les
centrales au charbon
la cour suprême a invalidé ces lois
soudain au trump la réglementation était
moins contraignante avec joe biden en
poste le pea fixe des cibles plus
ambitieuses
l'état de la virginie occidentale où
l'on retrouve de nombreuses centrales au
charbon ont fui lagence de protection
environnementale la question litigieuse
quels sont les pouvoirs réels de lagence
dans une décision rendue à 6 contre 3 le
juge en chef écrit que bien que
l'imposition de limites sur la
production de gaz carbonique soit sens
et il est peu plausible que le congrès
ait donné l'autorité à l' agence de
protection environnementale
d'adopter ses propres réglementations
le gouverneur de la virginie occidentale
applaudi cette décision
nous pouvons faire barrage à la gauche
radicale qui veut faire ce qui lui plaît
affirme le gouverneur mais qui ignorent
la logique et le bon sens
l'ancien dirigeant de l'agencé qualifie
ce jugement de catastrophique
c'est un autre exemple du refus de cette
cour de protéger la santé et la vie des
américains affirme-t-elle qu'il s'agisse
d'armes à feu d'avortement est
maintenant de changement climatique
les trois juges de la dissension
considère qu'aujourd'hui la cour a
arraché le pouvoir à l' agence de
protection environnementale de répondre
à l'enjeu le plus pressant de notre
époque
ce porte parole d'un organisme
environnemental juge qui sera plus
difficile de faire adopter des lois qui
est pose une réduction d'émission de gaz
carbonique
nous devrons peut-être faire des
compromis explique-t-il ce qui compte en
ce moment c'est d'agir tout de suite
parce que l' agence de protection
environnementale et notre outil le plus
important pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques
nous n'avons pas de temps à perdre un
gamin le folk et le président joe biden
parle lui aussi d'un jugement
catastrophique
par ailleurs cette décision ne tient pas
compte de la jurisprudence il ya 15 ans
la cour suprême avait établi que l'
agence de protection environnementale
pouvait et devait contrôler les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ici
valérie michael abeilles radio-canada
washington